ええええええ
me
4日
th
皆さんこんにちはえーっ
皆さんこんにちはあの今とダイバー
ご紹介にあずかりました法学部法律学科の日を一瞬と申します
あの今日は本当に素晴らしい海にあの
嬉しく思っています
準備とか大変だったかと思いますがまずもってお礼申し上げます
私はの量子力学とかそういう話はできないんですけど
聞いていただけたらと思っています
私は小学校のころから慶應義塾で学んでいるんですけれども
まあ今大学4年生であと12日くらいで卒業式を迎えるんですがまぁ卒業目前にして
思うのは本当にこの学校で学べてよかったなと
です
それこそ10この時のことを思い出しますとですね
私は10高校1年生の時に国際コンクールに挑戦した時があったんですがその
コンクールがちょうど学校の期末試験と重なっていたんです
その時に先生に相談しに行ったら
技術と
帰ってきたからいいかと
行く前に行ってもいいからとか行く前は結構大変なと思ったんですけどね
すごくよくしてくださって先生だけじゃなくてクラスのみんなもすごく応援して
くださったことをすごく覚えています
まだから今日こうやって卒業目前にして熟考に行こう帰ってくれることとっても嬉しく
そんな私が影響
私はきょうえねーずを皆さんにお姫いただくんですけれども
まあその前に少しだけ高校生の皆さんにメッセージをということだったので撮っても
僭越ながら一言だけ申し上げたいと思います私は諸先輩方のように
正しいことをしたわけでもなければそれ何がにより皆さんとあまり年が変わらないん
ですね
あのこう見えてもまだ22歳なんですね結構老けて見られることが多いですか
22歳ということはみなさんと6歳くらいしか変わらないん
僕は96歳の時にまだ
90歳ですからね多分買わない全然ハーフ
ね今日私が伝えたいことはですね
今自分が思っていることなんですが民家することというのはとっても大事だなと思って
いるということです
今と変化することってとっても第三高校の時は私のたこの事を気づいてなかったんです
が
大学4年になって卒業間近にして今とっても
この変化することの大切さをかみしめています
高校の時はちょっと完璧主義みたいのとか
何でしょうか
占いこととか初志貫徹とかそういうことばっかり大事だと思っていますもちろんそう
いうことも大事だと思うんですけれども
彼女とか作ると自分ブレイクしちゃう
そういうふざけたこと抜かしてまいりませんでしたけどね
あのー
なんですねっ
今
うってもこの大切さをかみしめています
この変化することの大切さに気づいたきっかけというのは私が大学1年生の時に
立ち上げた
オーケストラモチーフというオーケストラの活動に起因しています
まあ少しこのオーケストラの説明をさせていただきますと2012年の9月に私が中心
になって慶應義塾大学の学生や
東京芸術大学桐朋学園大学といった学校の垣根はこうやった学生たちが集まっていて
最初8人ぐらいで始めたんですが今は200人を超える大きな団体に
なりました
そのお客様もチーズもチーズという言葉はですね
フランス語で動機やきっかけを表す言葉で私たちは自分たちの音楽を通して誰かの
きっかけは背中を押す動機になりたいそういう思いで活動をしてきました例えば
ミャンマーに行ってミャンマーの子供たちが初めて
音楽を聴くきっかけを提供したい
あるいは福島県相馬市に行って子どもたちが初めて
ok したと一緒に演奏する機会をつくったりそういう活動をしてまいりました
そんなわけしたらも知事がミャンマーに行った時に
私にとってとっても大きなへんから
なんでマンミャンマーに行ったのかというところを少し説明させていただきますと皆
さんご存知の通り
ミャンマーという国は軍事政権から民主政権
大きな行こう
受けていぶ施設のか時の間に大きな経済発展を遂げた
んですそういった
発展の背後で社会問題というのが顕在化していました
まあそれはすなわち人身売買であったり
hiv であったりそういった問題で子どもが被害にあれば子どもが親を失うという
問題が
いましたん
そういった子どもたちをある種都市部から離れたところで生活させて
運営している医食住を提供している npo 法人ってのいくつかあるんですけれども
その一大きな一つに日本が日本の npo 法人ジャパンハートというところが気にし
ている
ドリームトレインという施設が
そのジャパンハートいうところの学生の代表当時の学生の代表があ
それこそ10校の先輩だったんですがこんな話をしてくれたんですねというのは子ども
たちは
犯罪から身を守るためにある種隔離された場所で生活しているから
年に1回か2回くらいしか外に出ることがないんだそうなんです
それも犯罪に巻き込まれないように動物園とかそういったところに行く
1回しっかり仕上げないみたいなということ
だから子供たち夢は何だのっていう聞くと
結構口をつぐんでしまうんだという話を聞いたんです
その話を聞いた時に他社ピンと来てです
自分も3歳でバレエを始めたんですけれどもまあ
音楽というものが何か彼らの
夢を目指すきっかけとか同期とかそういったものになるんじゃないかと思って山にこと
を決めました
まぁしかし私を含めてミャンマーに行った事がある人は誰もいなくてですね
まあ20人くらいで行ったんですけども実際に行くまでは本当に不安でした
子どもたちが本当に喜んでくれるだろうか自分たちがやっていることはあ正しいのか
どうかもわからないし
本当に不安でした
しかしそんな不安を乗り越えて実際に行ってみたらですね
ものすごく大きな
ことに気付いたと何かというといい意味で期待がスムース国裏切られたということなん
です
それは私たちはどこか恵まれない子どもたちもん
いた助けてあげるような
そんな気持ちがどこかあったように
実際に元気をもらっていたのはこっちの方だ学生の方だったんですね
日本人の学生の方が
ずっと元気をもらっていましたん
めぐマイナー生活してるんじゃないかと想像していた子どもたちは私たちがいかなくて
もものすごく他の人に元気に走り回っていました
そして何より私たちが学ぶべきことがたくさんあるな
彼らは子供から大人含めて皆親切です
それから目を輝かせているピラーにものを見るものというの
見る目というのは正直日本ではなかなか見ないなとそして自分たちもそうだったかなと
思いましたこれは参加したみんなそう言ってました
そういったことに
気付いたんです
その時に私は思いました
もチーズとか言って子供たちにかけようと葛藤貴音が入っていただけると思う
まさしく自分たちの動機やきっかけだったんだ
自分たちのために活動してたんだな
それが大きな変化でしっ
しかしですねしかしこういった話は結構あるかな
そんなに珍しくないのかなって思うんですね結構さん多分フェイスブックとか見てると
大学生が
どんなじゃあに行ったら人生変わりましたとかとナージャに行ったら考え方が変わり
ましたとか言ってることを見ることがあるかもしれない
そういう性質の話を聞けばいいんじゃないかと思うかもしれないんですが
私がこの経験がものすごく自分を変えたと思うのはなぜかというと
それは自分の頭で考えて変化したからだと
実際をケストラーモチーフをたちがて立ち上げた時もミャンマーに行く時もすごく反対
が大きかった実話
オーケストラでガンマそんなのできるわけないんじゃ
そんなお金があったらそんなと金と暇があったらワクチン打った方がいいんじゃないか
ということもありました
最も多かったのが
それ誰が前に行ったことある
誰かがやったことないのどんなんで君ができる乗ったようなこと言われたことがあり
ます
でもそういった人たちのことを聞いて止めていたら私は大切なことに気づかなかったか
なと思います
私が今日高校生のみなさんに伝えたいのは
に変化するということがとってもポジティブだということです
そして自分の頭で考えて変化することが特に男子たと
いますん
1頭
福澤先生がずーっと勉強していたヴァンダムを使おうと思ってい
横浜に行ってみたそこではオランダ方が全く話されてなかった
みんな英語を話していただから英語にガラッと勉強会たという人と聞いたことがあるか
もしれませんがそれは福澤先生はきっとご自分の頭で考えて変化することができたから
変わることができたんじゃないかなと思います
付和雷同してふわふわといろんなことに行ったり来たりするのとは違いますけれども
自分の頭で考えてそして自分のアタマで
考えだよピッターによって変化することはとってポジティブだということを伝えたいと
思います
最後になりますが
今からバーリーの演奏させていただきたいと思います
演奏数曲はバッハ作曲の梅林そあたぁ
大医馬
アンダンテという曲です
番花作曲楽曲は一ノガッパ版楽曲は全国に届くと言われることがありますが
そう言われるくらい
曲は人の心に寄り添い生の心を振るが生モノだと
拙い演奏ですがどうぞお聞き下さい
ふーん
eeaa
dea
衛兵
car
hey
re
dea
衛兵
yeah
teal
al
me
teal
dea
ja
ale
me
はぁ
dea
ああああああああ
yeah
いいえ
衛兵
yeah
ええっ
car
はぁ
hey hey
hey
ん
yeah
mar
衛兵
ふーん
naa
えーん
hey
yeah
ええええ
ana